hello welcome to ee380 stanford's
computer systems laboratory uh
colloquium on computer systems
um we have a speaker from the university
of vermont today
josh bongard who is going to talk to us
about uh computer designed organisms
that is uh well you'll find out about it
but
he's he's in the in the business of
making meat bots these days
any cases it should be an interesting
talk and
we look forward to uh your comments
uh josh the podium is yours
thank you thank you very much dennis and
uh thanks to all of you for your
interest in uh
as dennis mentioned meat bots otherwise
known as computer designed organisms
um so i'll just spend a minute uh
setting the stage before diving into
uh the subject itself um i'm josh
baumgardt i'm a professor of computer
science
here at the university of vermont and
the work i'm going to talk about today
is a collaboration with my phd student
sam kriegman
and our two biology colleagues doug
blackiston and michael levin
at tufts michael runs the allen
discovery center
at tufts university um and so as you can
tell just by looking at the
the title slide here this project is 50
computational and 50 biological so i
will
given the audience focus most of my uh
talk today on the computational aspect
of cdos
i will talk a little bit about the
biology but not too much
simply because i will rapidly exhaust my
uh knowledge and expertise in that area
if you are interested in in the
biological details of cdos
i refer you to doug and mike um
mike in particular might be an
interesting uh guest for your
your seminar series uh mike although
he's a biologist has a formal training
in computer science
and uh therefore is a great
interdisciplinary researcher as well and
is doing some amazing work
other than just computer designed
organisms
so um before again before you talk about
these little guys themselves
um i want to just sort of set the stage
about where i think
computer designed organisms fit within
the larger landscape of ai and robotics
and to describe this landscape i'm going
to use a geometric metaphor
and to start with i want you to imagine
we have a one-dimensional line segment
like you see here
and we can then represent uh agents or
robots
and the algorithms that train them as
embeddings in this one-dimensional space
so if you imagine any point uh
embedded in inside this line segment
that point could represent a trained
agent
a robot or as you'll see shortly a
computer designed organism
it is better or worse at some particular
task that we've posed
to the agent and you can then think of
your favorite
machine learning algorithm as a line
segment embedded in this segment
and that algorithm pushes points from
the left side of
its segment to the right side of its
segment and is obviously trying to
generate agents as far to the right
as possible and as we all know uh the
the deep learning revolution and the big
data revolutions have
allowed us to make rapid advances in
producing performant
uh machines if we continue this
uh geometric metaphor and add a second
dimension which
which are the tasks plural that we set
before
uh our machines we can still think of
any individual agent or robot
as a point in this now two-dimensional
uh space
the further to the right it is the
better at whatever it is we want it to
do
and the higher in this space that point
is
the better it is at a harder task like
nlp
compared to checkers or potentially it's
more general it's able to perform well
at a larger number of tasks
it doesn't really matter for our
discussion today this is just a bit of a
metaphor it's a little hand
wavy but the reason i use this metaphor
is like many roboticists i'm interested
i'm sorry before i get to the third
dimension we can sort of
think about how far we can push this
idea of
creating uh better and better machine
learning algorithms
and some people believe in agi some
don't
i don't really know what artificial
general intelligence means
artificial general and intelligence all
three of those terms are exceedingly
difficult to
uh to define but some people would argue
we just need bigger neural networks and
more data centers and more data
and that's it that's all we really need
and we'll eventually
will continue to produce increasingly
performant and increasingly general
agents but like many other roboticists
and others working
in ai in general i'm also interested in
a third dimension which is sometimes
known as
embodiment or morphology or body plan
embodiment is a controversial term it
means different things to different
people i'm not going to attempt to
define embodiment today
but most most people could look at the
atlas humanoid robot and the
humble roomba here and most would agree
that the atlas robot is
more embodied or is embodied in a more
complex manner than the roomba
the roomba is more embodied than a naked
neural network
running on a laptop waiting passively
for data so we can then ask the question
or we can start to think about
algorithms that
push along the grand diagonal so if you
imagine a line segment embedded in the
grand diagonal here that line segment
however it does it
is incrementally producing more
performant machines those further to the
right
slightly more general machines this
algorithm is exposing the agents to a
slowly growing set
of tasks or variants of a task
and finally this algorithm is pushing
towards the back
of the cube here and incrementally
complexifying or improving the
mechanical structure
of the machine so that's the algorithm
that i'm going to talk about today the
algorithm that produces
uh computer-designed organisms has these
three characteristics as we'll see
uh shortly so just to take an example of
how to sort of use this metaphor here's
some work by
a stanford grad carpathi
working with google did some amazing uh
work a few years back using the arm farm
here so seven robot arms trained over
uh four months 580 000 grasp attempts
were performed uh and generated data to
train a 1.2 million parameter neural
network
and at the end of those four months they
exposed these arms to
a set of new objects and the arms
performed well 96
percent of the time uh an incredible uh
an experi
an incredible experiment but if we then
try and embed this in this space
what it gives us is a line that moves
through a horizontal cut
through the cube these seven arms all
have
exactly the same embodiment and that
embodiment does not
did not change over the four month
period
of this of this experiment
so what happens if we relax that
assumption what happens if we assume now
that the body
uh or the bodies of each arm in the arm
farm here
changes significantly obviously there's
some insignificant wear and tear and so
on
but can we exploit the fact that the
embodiment of these
robots is changing to improve their
ability to learn
a set of tasks so as just an example of
this
several years ago now i worked on a
project with hod lipson at
cornell university where we assumed that
the change in embodiment was
unintentional and in this unintentional
change the robot suffered unexpected
damage damaged its morphology changed
and the control policy that had
previously been trained on the
intact robot uh no longer worked on the
uh on the damaged robot
we then did some model based control
where we assumed that the sensor motor
data being returned by the physical
machine was used to train
or adapt the model to better reflect the
robot's physical
state and then once it had adapted that
model it could retrain a control policy
and deploy it back to the damaged
machine
and allow it to recover functionality
i'm not going to talk about that work
today but just to give you a flavor for
the kinds of things we can explore when
we assume that the body
of the agents are changing over time
okay so another way to think about this
if you're more comfortable with
reinforcement learning is to take the
standard
five tuple where we assume the agent is
capable of a set s
of states it's capable of a set a of
actions
and we are trying to evolve or we're
trying to train
a policy to change state into action
we have some reward function that will
determine the quality of any given
uh policy and we have some subset f uh
sub f which is a subset of some desired
or final state
and finally we have the the transition
function which will take
the action at time t and translate it
into the new state
s t s sub t plus one that the agent
experiences at the next
time step i've introduced a slight
modification to this formalism here
which is to parameterize
uh the the uh transition matrix with
m sub i where m is some description
of the morphology or the embodiment uh
of this
agent and we can then a and in a
standard reinforcement learning
experiment of course it's the policy
that is the target of optimization
but what happens if the morphology
itself is changing
or better yet the morphology also or m
also becomes a target of optimization
obviously if we have an algorithm that
is changing
uh morphology from i to j in this case
it is also having impacts on s and
for example if we add or remove body
parts from
a machine we may increase or decrease
the dimensionality
of the state and action spaces we can
ask questions like if we make an
arbitrarily small
morphological modification under what
conditions can we
guarantee that there will be a
correspondingly small
change in the state state the new state
space
and action space for this new machine
we can then generalize that and think
about what the biologists refer to as
morphospace which is the space of all
possible
uh morphologies and we can then think
about moving through the space
and looking for gradients can we for
example move from one morphology to
another
in morpho space and climb a gradient
towards some desired
meta state for example searching for
morphologies
that increasingly facilitate an inner
loop of policy training
for example those are the kinds of
things we work on in my group and we've
looked at that with
simulated and physical rigid and soft
robots
but today we're going to talk about
neither of those and focus instead on
meat bots of course
my group is not the first to think about
this most of you will probably be
familiar with the
groundbreaking work of carl sims all the
way back in the early 1990s
carl sims was a computer graphics
researcher among other things
created his own physics engine six years
before there were any commercially
available physics engines
and then created at that time an
evolutionary algorithm that could
simultaneously alter the body plans and
control policies
of virtual creatures it was a
groundbreaking
uh report at the time and is still in
many ways considered state of the art
it's very difficult to improve upon carl
sims's work
one of the reasons for that is that when
we are searching through
morphology space it is very difficult to
guarantee
that we have a differentiable system and
so
i'm going to hopefully try and convince
some of you that this is an interesting
problem to work on
there is an open sub problem in this
problem which is
can we create differentiable algorithms
that are able to move continuously
through morpho space
looking for morphologies that admit or
facilitate
the inner loop of policy training okay
so let's switch now and talk about
applying this idea to
robots that are made out of biological
cells this was work that we reported
just this past
january in pnas i'm going to talk about
the algorithm itself
and show you some images and videos of
the
uh cdos in action all the images and
videos i'm going to show you today are
available on a website we created for
this project
uh in the lower left there there's also
a pointer there to the github repo so
you can dig into the code if you're
interested
there's a link to the paper itself and
other materials
so as as promised as i just mentioned
we're going to look at a nested
algorithm in which there is an outer and
inner loop
of training and i'm going to start with
this outer loop of training and in this
outer loop what we're going to do is
continuously design
virtual creatures not that differently
from how
carl sims did back in the 90s for each
promising design we are then going to
deploy it into a physical environment
and see how well that physically
um how well the physical agent does
compared to the simulated agent
this is very closely related to uh sim
to re their sim
real problem uh in robotics if you think
it's difficult to
successfully transfer a relatively
traditional robot from simulation to
reality or just a control policy
from sim to real it's particularly
challenging when we're trying to cross
uh what what my phd student sam calls
not sim to real but sim to life
okay so i just want to talk about this
algorithm a little bit um we're going to
assume that the investigator supplies a
series
of tasks you can think of these as
reward functions if you like
we are also going to supply beta which
is a description of the
physical building blocks from which the
agent can be built
in some related work in soft robotics we
build soft robots
out of soft voxels that can increase and
decrease their local volumes
um in this case as promised the building
blocks are going to be cells that are
drawn
from xenopus slavis the african
claude frog we are also going to require
a couple of other parameters i'll just
refer to these as
theta i'm not going to go into too many
details of these but you can think of
these as constraints
that we are going to draw back or we are
going to
distill out of the organisms out of the
computer-designed organisms
and those constraints are going to be
information that allow us to
improve our simulation and improve our
ability
to uh or increase the likelihood of a
successful cinderella transfer
during the next iteration through this
uh outer loop
this is an idea uh that's again a very
popular and sim to reel at the moment
which is to collect
sensor motor experiences from the
physically deployed plant
and use that sensor motor data to
automatically
reverse engineer or improve the
simulation or the transition matrix that
we're using to
train our virtu our virtual agents
okay so then we're going to go through
this infinite loop where we're going to
start by
training an agent to perform some task
and that agent can be
built out of some arbitrary number of
the building blocks in beta and we're
going to train them in some simulation
that's been parameterized or constrained
by theta so let me unpack this
training algorithm a little bit this is
actually the the middle loop there are
actually
three nested loops of optimization here
i'm only going to talk about the outer
and middle loops today we're going to
start by generating a population
of bodies so we're going to be using a
population-based
stochastic gradient descent method
otherwise known as an evolutionary
algorithm
i'll talk about the evolutionary
algorithm in a moment but before i do
let me talk about the way that we encode
bodies in the system we're going to
describe each body or we're going to
encode it as a computational pattern
producing network or cppn
this is a data structure developed by
stanley
and it's loosely based on biological
development
and you'll see why in a moment a cppn as
the name promises is a network
and here is a cartoon cppn here it has
two input neurons and one output neuron
what a cppn does is travel
over a a space of arbitrary dimension
and paint a pattern into that space
not unlike a developing organism that is
developing
in a in an egg sac or is developing
uh in a womb and there are chemical
gradients that are induced into that
space
and we start to lay down increasingly
complex patterns
across space in a developing embryo
in this cartoon example here we have
just two coordinates x and y so we're
going to paint a regular pattern
in space what we do is to take this
particular cppn visit the first position
in the space x equals 0 y a equals 0
propagate those two input values to the
output
neuron here g you can see that only x
is connected to g so the so at this
point x equals zero doesn't matter what
the synaptic weight is we're gonna get a
g
of zero and place no gray at position
x equals y equals zero
we then move to the next point in the
space we supply
that set of coordinates to the input
layer of the network
the value arriving at g dictates how
much gray to paint onto that pixel
and we continue that process for some
regular lattice in the space
and this simple cartoon cppn gives us a
horizontal gradient if we then
randomly perturb or mutate this uh
network in some way
where we now have a single synaptic
connection going from y
to g you can convince yourself that this
cppn will produce a regular vertical
gradient
we can also perturb the activation
functions in the neurons in this case
replacing sigmoid with a step function
and this gives us a discrete
gradient in this case and if we allow an
increasing number
of hidden layers with arbitrary synaptic
weights connecting them
an arbitrary activation functions
we start to get more and more complex
patterns like you see
uh in f so what is a computer what is
the cppn doing as you might be able to
see
by now depending on the architecture and
the weights
of the network it arbitrarily decomposes
coordinate transforms
inside a space and then paints or
deposited some material
based on those composed transforms
you can uh it's obviously independent of
dimension we can paint regular patterns
in three-dimensional space we could add
t
as an input neuron and paint regular
patterns over time
this is a relatively common type of
generative networks
if instead of trying to train a
recognizer
we instead want to generate interesting
or useful
patterns which in our case are going to
be
robots that are made out of in
simulation
voxels but in reality frog cells
so we're now going to take cppns and
following the work of
cheney adele back in 2014 we're going to
take a cppn
and ask it to determine which voxels
exist
inside an empty three-dimensional space
and for each voxel that's deposited the
cppn is also going to paint
one of four colors onto that
voxel only three of the four colors are
shown here
so we have x y and z we're gonna we're
gonna visit
uh 3d coordinates in the space
and we have two output neurons the first
output neuron presence we're going to
uh scale this to a binary value zero
means no voxel is placed at that
position
one indicates yes a voxel is placed at
that position
if a voxel is deposited in that position
we scale the
value of the second output neuron to an
integer from one to four
and that integer indicates which color
to paint onto that voxel
so we've now created uh an arbitrary
three-dimensional shape and you can
again
play around with creating different
cppns and imagine how they produce
different shapes and different
distributions of colors
onto those voxels we're going to use
those colors
as pointers into material properties
what do i mean by material properties
once we have this 3d structure
we embed it in or we send it to a
finite element soft body simulator
in our case we use vox cad this was
originally developed by
hodlipson at cornell we've recently
adapted this to run on
gpus so we can simulate very high
resolution soft body
mechanics um what you can see here
are these three different materials at
play um
the red and green voxels are meant to be
actuated voxels so we assume there's a
local actuator
in each red and green voxel that can
increase or decrease the volume of that
voxel
all red voxels oscillate in phase with
one another
so we also assume there is a local
a distributed open loop controller all
the green voxels oscillate in phase with
one another
and red and green voxels oscillate and
anti-phase with one another so
loosely based on the idea of agonist and
antagonistic muscle groups
the light blue voxels that you see are
passive
uh passive soft material like fat
uh like fatty tissue
and we can then um and i'll show you
how we then evolve these cppn's in a
moment but before i do as i mentioned
what we're doing
is creating an initial population
of bodies on line one here we're then
going to run an evolutionary algorithm
that is going to
evolve different body plans and
different
material distributions over a number of
generations
for each body in the population at each
generation
we can call an inner loop of training
that will train a particular policy
for that body in the cdo's you're going
to see today
there is no policy so like like the
robot we just described here there is no
separate neural control policy it is
sort of
implicit in the structuring of the body
depending on where we place
these red and green voxels we get
different uh behavior
so we're going to assume that the policy
itself or the starting policy is
dictated by
theta the thetas which you'll remember
are things that we're learning from
the physically deployed agent in our
case it's it's going to be these
computer designed organisms
assuming we do we do have the
possibility of training
a policy for this specific specific body
we can run a relatively standard
reinforcement learning
uh method in here where we have the
unrolled loop
in line five here we update state we
update reward
and we might return the total reward
obtained by the policy for this body so
we're
assuming we run this what what algorithm
1.2 gives us back
is the total reward for a given body if
we cannot change the policy or there is
no policy
then we simply run the body in
simulation or in reality
and somehow measure or integrate reward
over that simulation and return that
value so
after line four here we assume that we
have evaluated every body
and we have a reward associated with
that body
we then uh we then as i mentioned we're
going to run this forward over a number
of generations so this is a screenshot
this is a video again not from not from
our cdo project but from chinese work in
it shows a nice sort of visualization of
how this evolutionary algorithm
manipulates populations of cppns
what you're seeing in the top half of
the video is the best uh
the the body that obtains the highest
reward or
what we would say in an evolutionary
algorithm the greatest fitness
you'll notice that evolution is
exploring the morpho space
of these voxel-based robots you'll
notice that it is
sampling body plans that have different
three-dimensional shape
and also different distributions of the
red and green muscle groups
and in a few of them you'll see small
amounts of light blue
which is fat dark blue uh
bone of the analog of bone not
surprisingly at least in retrospect what
does evolution do it converges on
basically balls of muscle because the
reward function here is simply
uh disturbance over time there's no
penalty for
energy usage okay
in the work i'm going to show you in a
moment for cdos we used a
more modern evolutionary algorithm the
age fitness predo optimization method
this is a multi-objective
optimization method i'm not going to go
into details of it but one of the nice
things
about athpo is that it maintains
genetically independent species
inside the same population so what
you're looking at in this figure here
this is a
typical result from running afo we have
number of generations or
computational effort if you like on the
horizontal axis
and the vertical axis is reward or
fitness which in this case
is body length traveled
each colored line shows that the
most visual from that species so we can
see there are many
species at any given time you can see
the pink
dinosaurs here sort of plateau in
fitness after a while
and the light blue mammals here which
for quite a while are much worse than
the dinosaurs
after many generations of mutation and
genetic recombination
eventually field a light blue robot that
travels faster
than the best magenta dinosaur robot
what what appo does as you can probably
guess is it probabilistically samples
from
different uh subpopulations or species
which have discovered local optima and
those that are
higher in the space better local optima
are
are preferentially sampled from
okay okay so again back to
uh computer designed organisms so when
we run this we're using the vox cad
voxel-based simulator and when we run
this and we select for
forward uh displacement when we're
working with cdos
our set beta contains only two lego
bricks there are only two
types of voxels that
the algorithm can use red voxels which
like in chinese work are going to pulse
at a regular frequency they're going to
increase and decrease their volume
at a set at a set frequency
and also green voxels none of which you
see in this evolved body plan here
the green voxels are meant to be passive
soft
material when we actually run this
uh we actually visit line three
100 times so we run 100 independent
evolutionary algorithms and each
evolutionary algorithm gives us back the
body plan with the highest reward or
fitness
from that evolutionary algorithm and you
can see what the biologists refer to as
convergent
evolution here although there are robots
that have different shapes they are all
basically balls of muscle you'll notice
also that they are all bilaterally
symmetric which is a good thing to have
if you're interested in forward
locomotion
and remember that each one of these body
plans has an underlying cppn that
generates it
as i mentioned earlier when we talked
about cppns
one of the nice things about cppns is
they tend to
paint regular patterns in space if we
randomly wire up a cppn it gives us a
non-random pattern
in the painted space we do not get white
noise so part of the reason why cppns
are referred to as
abstractions of development as they
compose coordinate transforms
which biases search if you're searching
over the space of all cppns
if biases search towards things that
have symmetries
symmetries embedded in symmetries
gradients
repeated patterns and so on
okay so now that we have our 100
trained agents we would like to deploy
them
and uh this is where things get
interesting
um in this case as i mentioned we're
going to deploy it we're going to build
these robots out of frog
out of frog cells so we sent those 100
designs
to doug blackiston who's a very
accomplished microsurgeon
at tufts and i'm going to walk you
through how he goes about
attempting to build one of these designs
step one is to take fertilized embryos
from
zetacus levis and inject a marker
and some other proteins that influence
the stem cells
inside these embryos to grow towards
either
uh ectoderms so skin cells
or pre uh cardiac precursor cells so
cells that are somewhere between stem
cells and heart muscle cells
um after a couple days he then removes
the vitaline membranes this is sort of
the egg sac
around uh the embryo you'll see him here
with micro forceps removing
uh removing this gelatinous covering
from one of these
impregnated fertilized frog embryos
he's then going to remove uh the cap
from
each of these embryos each cap contains
several thousand or tens of thousands
of these um of cells some of these cells
are epithelial cells ectoderms skin
cells
some are going to be cardiac cells let
me see if i can speed this up for you
again all these videos are available on
the website
as you can imagine this is very pain
painstaking work
after removing uh some of these caps
they're placed in a solution which
causes the cells to dissociate
so you can see the white cells here and
again if i speed this up you'll see
doug removing some of the cap or the
unwanted material so basically what
we're trying to do is dissociate these
cells
and doug is then going to manipulate
them to reforming
into the desired shape and material
distributions
and
okay
so after we have these dissociated cells
um
they're going to uh doug is going to
inject them into a very small
well where just because of the concavity
of the well they start to
naturally collect together
and if they're left for a while
okay so they're injected into the wells
i think this is uh you can see the
individual cells themselves
and the these are going to be basically
the xenobot
once it forms into the right shape
it can be anywhere from a few thousand
to a few tens of thousands
of cells and dissociated frog cells
will tend to try and associate together
so they're left in these wells for a few
days where they gradually
re-aggregate as they do during this
process
we can layer different cell types
together so depending
on the distribution of uh heart muscle
cells
and ectoderm cells doug can basically
lay down
a meat sandwich so layers of ecto
layers of uh of
skin cells and heart muscle cells
you can see in this video a little bit
better how over
uh two days they are re-aggregating and
basically
form back into a ball of cells
with at least generally speaking
skin and heart muscle cells where we
want them
and then in the very last steps here
doug takes one of these target designs
for example a quadrupedal shape like you
see here
and then using using a cauterization
tool
and again the micro forceps he's able to
very carefully
shape this into the desired shape
so you can see him selectively
cauterizing or removing some material
some of the cellular material
as you can tell from this process um in
the
cdo project at the moment design has
been automated
using an evolutionary algorithm but the
manufacture process
is still very much a manual process
okay this is towards the end now where
he's starting to
to sculpt this into its final shape um
in this particular case as you can see
in the target shape on the left
this particular organism is or this this
particular construct is only made from
skin cells this is actually how this
project uh got started
um uh the tufts group and mine are
co-funded through a darpa project and on
our weekly call we were
showing our tufts colleagues some of our
evolved virtual creatures
next week doug came back and
demonstrated
uh that he had made a sculpture of one
of these
uh one of our virtual creatures out of
frog skin cells
it's just a sculpture at this point it
doesn't move but that suggested to us
perhaps we could get these
things to move by adding in eventually
cardiac cells i don't think i mentioned
yet but these
uh current xenobots are very small um
they're less than a millimeter uh in
diameter about 750
microns across okay so
that's the deployment stage
in this particular paper however it
turns out that the vast
number of evolved designs were
non-manufacturable
and so we basically worked out a
protocol or doug worked out a protocol
which you can see as a flowchart on the
right which determines
whether or not we're able to uh whether
or not we're able to actually
build uh one of a particular design
so in panel a we ranked all of our
100 designs by by fitness a reward how
well they were
in the case of the best design
it did not have contiguous muscle cell
regions so there were separate groups of
muscle
at the moment in this manual
construction process there was no way to
build this
so that design failed due to condition
b1
it also failed due to b3 which is that
it was not
mostly passive tissue as i showed you
before
most of these creatures are 100
100 uh muscle cells which is
particularly difficult to do
and i'll talk a little bit about that in
a moment they some of them did not have
a stable geometry some of them had
overly complex
shapes that doug couldn't build as i
mentioned the cells generally like to
try and re-aggregate
so if there's a concavity anywhere on
the surface of the
of the shape if it's too small the
z phenobot as it's growing will
basically just fill
fill this in so
in this case none of the 100 designs
were real
real realizable in reality so we use
that information
to again modify the constraints of the
simulation
what we did in this case was to build in
a particular constraint
that that became apparent due to all
these failed designs and that is that
and this constraint is as follows if you
arbitrarily place cardiac tissue in the
xenobots
obviously those cardiac tissues are put
together in a shape that is very
different from a developing
frog heart and it is hard to predict how
those cardiac cells
will behave so we built in a constraint
that first of all these cardiac cells
are weaker
so it doesn't make sense to build a big
ball of muscle
we also assumed back in simulation that
since we have no understanding of how
cardiac cells will or will not
spontaneously synchronize
when put together in arbitrary
configurations
we assumed and said instead that in
simulation
any any cardiac cells will beat at
random
so what you're seeing in these three
videos are three
random cppns producing three random
softbots and the way that we
the way that we simulate this is we
assume that all the cardiac cells have
exactly the same
frequency and amplitude but they all
have
differing phase offsets so they're all
beating at random
what that means in general is that what
the evolutionary algorithm is now going
to have to do
is try and design the shape of one of
these things to effectively
de-randomize the collection at the
collective action
of the cardiac cells and channel
all of those independently randomly
acting
forces into forward locomotion
so as a metaphor imagine you had a whole
bunch of human rowers
but they were all going to row at the
same frequency but at different phase
offsets
and your task is to build the shape of a
boat so that when you put these human
rowers in the boat
the boat will go straight i have not
been able to figure out how to do this
manually it's a very non-intuitive
design task which is exactly what
evolutionary algorithms
are well suited for so
the first time through this outermost
loop as i showed you we got these 100
evolved balls of muscle
we failed to cross the sim to life
gap but we learned something in that
failed transferal
which we used to improve the biological
veracity of
the simulation and when we iterated this
loop again
and built in these constraints uh using
theta
we got back these 100 uh
these 100 designs as you can see in this
second pass through
the outer loop there are combinations of
passive tissue
i'm sorry which is the cyan the cyan
voxel so these correspond
to frog epithelial tissue
and red is the cardiac tissue you also
see lots lots of different shapes
you'll notice there are a couple of
empty cages here which are kind of
interesting
these evolve because we put in a little
bit of hydrodynamics so the
xenobots operate inside a petri dish
with uh with water and so we put that
put that in the simulation as well
turns out that this empty cage was
exacted in a later experiment by us to
carry a small payload
let me show you the best uh the best of
all of these designs which is in here
somewhere
here it is and you'll see it in this
video operating in silico
and doug actually did manage to
successfully build
this design it more or less has the same
shape as the simulated xenobot
and has cardiac tissue mostly on the
ventral or bottom
surface of the xenobot and mostly
passive skin cells
on the top okay so this is just
anecdotal evidence that we could cross
the sim
uh to life gap so
let me talk a little bit more about this
gap the first thing we looked at in the
paper was to
talk about um the the ability to
transfer
shape so here the actual here's the
actual built xenobot down here
we used we used some computer graphics
methods to compare
the shape and the distribution of
materials in silico
to in reality and vivo and it turns out
that
on average the error was about 40
percent of the diameter of the agent so
not
very good but not bad definitely better
than chance and surprisingly that
although the shapes were quite a bit
different
we were able to preserve behavior from
simulation into reality so although
transferal of form was very noisy
transferal of function
worked pretty well here's some
quantitative data
so what you're seeing in the bottom plot
is
uh five different instances so so
um doug built five xenobots based on
this design
and ran each of those five xenobots
three or four time
times in a petri dish and recorded the
trajectory on the bottom of the petri
dish
which are the blue trajectories there
should be about 20 or 24 of them
the pink trajectories are our
predictions
from simulation about how this design
would move
remember that i told you that the
individual red voxels are
beating in random phase offsets with
each other
so if we replay back this design and
simulation multiple times
we get the pink curves
as you can see generally speaking
there's a preferential movement in
towards uh greater x which is the
direction we evolved
the xenobots to move in to determine
that it was actually the shape that was
leading to displacement we took each of
these five as xenobot designs and
flipped them on
their back we did the same thing in
simulation
and in both cases that disrupted the
ability to locomote
which tells us not only can we cross uh
the sim to life gap here
but that transfer that predict the
behavior predicted from the simulated
design
that behavior is a function of the shape
and distribution of tissue throughout
the body
okay so again not a perfect transferal
but but good enough to get the behavior
we were interested in
we then did some other experiments other
than just locomotion
it turns out that if you take these uh
xenobots evolve for locomotion
and put multiple instances of them in a
simulator you get this kind of behavior
that you see in the top
and you get more or less the same
behavior uh
in the bottom the xenobots themselves
are slightly
uh slightly adhesive and they also have
com you know complex three-dimensional
structure
so if they uh come in contact with one
another
uh and apply oblique forces against one
another they do a little bit of this
square dance
and then move off and possibly connect
with another partner
we also noticed um in a third experiment
uh sorry i forgot to mention uh we uh
doug tried out a bunch of these xenobots
in a petri dish this is us looking down
into the petri dish
uh doug sprinkled the bottom of the
petri dish with very small
particulate matter and you can see that
you can see the traces or the
trajectories of these
xenobots and they also lead to
piles of particulate matter it is not
clear whether that happens just through
this the
statistical mechanics of these uh
randomly moving xenobots
or if they are somehow spontaneously
sensing and acting on their environment
so xenobots are very much like the
inverse of traditional robots if you've
ever worked with robots
they tend to do less or worse of what
you expect them to do
you need to put a huge amount of effort
into
embedding desirable functions into them
xenobots although they're designed in
computer they
also come equipped with four and a half
billion years of experience with
grappling with the real world and they
will spontaneously exhibit
behaviors of their own even behaviors
that were not selected for
in the evolutionary algorithm we're
working on a follow-up paper now to
understand whether
this uh spontaneous creation of piles
is actually non-random if if perhaps
these frog cells
or the cells that make up the xenobots
although they don't have any sense
organs or or muscle groups per se
cells do talk to one another even when
they're put together in arbitrary
configurations
and they the cells in any one xenobot
may be spontaneously
coordinating their action to give rise
to interesting behavior like
collecting piles you can see this at the
micro scale here
where sam evolved in simulation a robot
to push
an obstacle and this was inspired
actually
by an observation in vivo here you see
a xenobot which seems to be circling
and like a little small sheepdog
shepherding this small piece of
particulate matter
forward this was actually
life to sim so we were inspired by this
behavior and wanted to see if we could
evolve
robots to do it so again these xenobots
seem to have some spontaneous
useful behaviors one of the most
important
behaviors that come for free from most
of the xenobots we've created
is that if you damage them in this case
doug is cutting one almost in half
you'll notice that after a few hours
it's able to
gradually uh heal itself
i've worked with robots for a while
where we cut off one of the legs it
obviously never grows a leg back or
spontaneously deforms to minimize
or cancel out the insult so
again by building robots out of
biological cells we get a lot of
spontaneous
useful behavior for free
okay um just to sort of close up now i i
i'm getting close to uh the end of my
talk here just to sort of situate
xenobots or computer-designed organisms
in the larger landscape of synthetic
biology i've added one branch to
synthetic biology here which are all
living constructs which have been
designed by a computer or an ai
or a machine learning algorithm
what i've just introduced to you are
computer-designed organisms
from the ground up there's no assumption
on our part about what the shape is or
the patterning of the cardiac
tissue no assumptions about bilateral
symmetry how big these things should be
and so on and the degrees of freedom
that the evolutionary algorithm had at
hand to design these
is to reconfigure the placement of
tissue
so we referred to these in the paper as
reconfigurable organisms
the reason why we worked with xenopus
levis is it's a very forgiving
model species mike's group has
demonstrated in the past that you could
graft
an eye onto the back of a developing
frog embryo
and not only will that eye be functional
in the adult frog but that eye will
spontaneously connect to the spinal
cord and the adult frog will be able to
direct behavior without
using the eye on its back so the
developmental trajectory of
frogs is incredibly permissive and that
led mike
and doug to think about how far
away from the default developmental
trajectory of frogs could we push things
and in this case could we get a computer
to design an
alternate developmental trajectory with
some perturbations from
outside to produce novel
frogs that are not frogs or at least
frogs that end up
with an adult shape very different from
the default shape
um another branch of synthetic biology
is um
human-designed bio-hybrids
not so much human-designed organisms yet
this is
an older an idea that's been around for
a while now
in the literature here's some early work
uh by now roth in in 2012
basically embedding heart cells in a
silicone jellyfish
so we have a combination of artificial
and biological materials thus
biohybrids
more recently park and his colleagues
created a very small
biohybrid stingray so in this case they
were able to culture
rat cardiac tissue on either wing
of uh of the ray and with some human
ingenuity they were able to
optogenetically control the heart muscle
cells on either side
of the of the stingray so that light
falling on the front left
of the stingray would trigger a
cascading contraction
from the anterior to the posterior side
of that wing
causing it to beat faster or slower than
the wing on the other side receding
receiving less light stimulation and
therefore
in the design produce manually designed
machines capable
of phototaxis or photophobia
so we're also working at the moment on
other computer-designed organisms that
are constructed from
other species other than xenopus lavis
those are not being built by
reconfiguring cellular tissues together
but
altering their developmental
trajectories in other ways
and stay tuned there will be
publications about this forthcoming
one final note about the machine
learning here as i mentioned we used an
evolutionary algorithm
evolutionary algorithms are unsatisfying
for a lot of people because you could
not guarantee
convergence on the flip side however it
is very difficult to see how to apply
a standard stochastic gradient descent
method
to designing body plans because again it
is difficult to estimate
gradients when we're adding and removing
physical material so to test this
we did a study where we took a very
small xenobot so these were xenobots
that could only be built inside a two
by two by two space
which leads to uh slightly uh six and a
half thousand
possible designs
and within that space for randomly
contracting cardiac
cells it turns out that there are five
optimal
solutions that you see here so we can
enumerate
all of the all of the designs and know
the morphle space
perfectly the morphospace is made up of
these 6500 possible designs
and given the control policy which are
these randomly contracting
cardiac tissues these are the five
designs that travel faster than any of
the other 6557
56 designs
so that gave us the ceiling of
performance here we ran our
athpo algorithm as i described to you in
green and
after about 9000 evaluations it found
one of these five optimal designs
it took a little bit longer for uh
more standard sgd methods to do so
and the reason why is in this case
because we had to convert the policies
into discrete values so the policy now
is a set of eight
uh eight ternary ternary values
which indicate uh whether or not to
place a voxel there so zero is place no
voxel at that
position one is place a cardiac
cell at that position two is place uh
is to place a skin cell at that position
and we need to then find uh the gradient
or estimate the gradient
in this discrete policy space which is
particularly difficult to do and is as
far as we know non-differentiable
if anybody has an idea about how to
create differentiable policy gradient
descent
when policies policies uh
parameters have discrete values we would
love to hear from you
we then re-ran this in a slightly larger
morphle space that contains
over 500 000 possible designs this this
we could still exhaustively uh search
and determine
the best the five best designs here
which have this performance uh have and
it turns out that in this case the
evolutionary algorithm found these
optimal designs after about 4 000
evaluations in simulation the other two
sgd methods that we looked at performed
poorly
and they be performed even worse
compared to the evolutionary algorithm
when we moved to a higher space
which again was just on the edge of us
being able to enumerate
all possible designs so we knew what the
optimal design was
in each of these three spaces we knew
that with this computational effort the
evolutionary algorithm could
consistently find it
the stochastic gradient descent methods
could not
so still a lot of work to be done here
about what is the right search method
for
simultaneously searching over designs
and possibly
also searching over an inner loop of
policy optimization
for any individual design
these are some of the best designs
produced by
the the sgd method that we used here by
senka
and now you can see that they look very
different
from the designs produced by the
evolutionary algorithm
thanks again to the cppn that produce
these designs so an evolutionary
algorithm armed with cppns is
biased towards searching parts of the
morpho space that contain
uh designs with symmetry and repetition
uh and so on
the other methods uh do not
okay so i think just to uh start to wrap
up here i've introduced this idea
i've introduced computer-designed
organisms where we use an evolutionary
algorithm to discover
novel forms meaning adult phenotypes
that do not
exist in nature and we're searching for
novel forms that have desired function
which in this case was simply forward
locomotion or object manipulation
design was automatic but manufacture was
manual
you can read more find out more about cd
cd orgs at that website
future work that we're looking at is can
we gain
control over spontaneously appearing
useful functions so the xenobots will
spontaneously
uh stitch themselves back together after
damage
they seem to spontaneously go after and
collectively shepherd material
in their in their environment but at the
moment we have no control over that we
have no understandable mapping from
form to these spontaneous functions
we'd obviously like to automate the
manufacture of cd organisms we're
looking at bioprinters
or bioelectric fields to influence the
growth and movement
of dissociated cells
doug is also hard at work in adding new
tissue types beyond just skin and heart
muscle cells
we could also graft in or allow the
evolutionary algorithm to arbitrarily
place different sense organs in the
xenobots
other kinds of actuators so at the
moment we just looked at muscle
but frogs also have cilia or very small
hairs
on their skin that they usually use to
propagate
a mucous membrane and wash wash off
their skin
but we can also appropriate those cilia
for beating
for beating and swimming uh in in a
fluid
we could also graft in a nervous tissue
and we could also potentially combine or
build
xenobots out of cells other than those
from xenopus
which we tongue-in-cheek refer to as
chimera bots
and finally also looking at automated
improvement of this sim to life
transferal process at the moment we were
very we spent a lot of time
observing failed transfers and inferring
from that
what to improve in the simulator we'd
like to
adapt some of the data-driven sim to
real methods from robotics
uh for this application
uh my mike levin is uh very interested
in what he call
what he call refers to as cracking the
bioelectric code so cells talk to one
another using electricity even if they
are not
neurons could we design xenobots not to
move
quickly but to advertise how their cells
communicate
in a given form to produce some desired
function
at the moment when we try and perturb or
observe an existing organism usually we
kill it
but could we instead create xenobots
that are more amenable
to simultaneously observation of form
bioelectric communication among the
cells and
function we're also interested in
finding new collaborators there's
clearly lots of directions we could go
with computer-designed organisms so if
you're interested in this project please
do send me or my biology colleagues
a note finally i'll close by obviously
acknowledging the other three members
of this project and darpa for for
funding all of this work
so thanks very much and i'll finish up
there